it's well known that former basketball
player Sue bird and Soccer Star Megan
rapino are in a relationship did you
know that Sue bird and her former
college teammate Diana Taurasi once
drank Megan rapino under the table in
2020 during quarantine the couple took
to Instagram live to share stories of
the past bird and rupino took a trip to
Hawaii with Bird's fellow Yukon alumna
and several other WNBA Stars the group
began drinking in the early afternoon
and apparently rupino couldn't keep up
with the others it's vacation drinks
Diana doing the pores strong pores
rupino was caught throwing up in a plan
and ended the night passed out on the
bathroom floor Sue bird summed it up by
saying I'm just gonna say this right now
for anyone asking you can't drink with
Yukon players